hey everyone Deadpool 2 is the new
superhero movie that everyone is now
turning their sights to for a more
hopefully light-hearted change of pace
from the heartbreak that was infinity
war but one big question on the eve of
Deadpool's premiere who is this secret
cameo that the movie added during
resuits did ryan reynolds finally
convince Hugh Jackman to who take an
encore battle Pro for a fellow weapon
exilim to New Zealand I think the
technical term is New Zealand II talk
about Deadpool - if model can never
forgive you for that terrible accent
first welcome to New York star's news
everyone it's a deep dive into all the
biggest stories from this week we're
also going to talk about infinity war
and a big plot detail that might have
been dropper Avengers for and possible
titles for future MCU movies news about
Rick and Morty and soullow a Star Wars
story and more we got it all here you
don't need to go look at other places
just come here every Friday and then
join us I'm Erik Voss joining me at this
table are over here Sam hi everybody hi
I'm it feels pretty good and I'm DJ
Wilkinson they let me back welcome
everybody
ok let us start with our top story
Deadpool - the premiere is only a week
away and Deadpool has been celebrating
with a number of goofy Bromo spots he
danced in high heels alongside Celine
Dion in the ashes music video so great
he also did a sketch with David Beckham
and pologize him for making fun of his
voice in the first movie he also
released a Deadpool demands your silence
parody letter of the Infinity war Thanos
to man through silence letter it's
pretty great you should have really read
it it does have some naughty words in it
because this is Deadpool that's how it
goes
but in these final weeks the appearances
that have caused the most speculation
have been once with Hugh Jackman I'm not
even trying accent this time a few
months back the movie's reshoots
included a new secret cameo leading fans
to wonder if Wolverine or Hugh Jackman
might make an appearance in the movie
Hugh Jackman of course is shot down
these rumors repeatedly in the past
last year the film's writers were open
to the idea of it hoping to get maybe a
clever spin on it maybe wade could meet
Hugh as Hugh the actor who of course
exists in the world of the
the Wade Ward the sexiest man alive
cover which was huge Ackman so he is in
that world somewhere recently Deadpool
showed up in a Twitter video that Hugh
Jackman made for a fan leading everyone
to wonder what they were doing together
and then this week Jackman went on Good
Morning America and sent a special
message to Ryan Reynolds joking back it
up a little with Reynolds request for
him to make a cameo he said play a
little hard to get it's too much it's
not sexy do you guys think it's possible
that all this playfulness and this
banter could be teasing a cameo by Hugh
Jackman or Wolverine and Dipple - and if
not Hugh Jackman who would you like the
secret cameo is the best person on the
planet currently yeah yeah he's great
also I love that you like broke down
it's like well if the magazine exists
and if Hugh Jackman and Wolverine exist
I want then in this movie they'll meet
for one second shake hands and that'll
be the end of it no it'll be a it
probably is just gonna be Hugh Jackman
showing up and I I'm fine with I hope I
hope it is Hugh Jackman is Hugh Jackman
though I I want them to have a retired
Wolverine with Logan right right and
they pull like a John Noble on legends
of tomorrow where it's just it's him as
the actor yeah I have a feeling it's
gonna be a huge Jackman is going to
punch Deadpool in the face and be like
Ryan stop it yeah it's I think anything
that Deadpool says to camera can be
construed as like this is just outside
of the universe of this show or of the
the movie like doesn't have a joke at
the beginning of the first Deadpool
where he mentioned something like he
gives a shout out to Hugh Jackman right
before he does the maximum effort jump
down into the motorcade yeah he does
some kind of joke talk about the first
Deadpool iteration there's so many
little joke like you in the most recent
trailer breakdown you had the thing of
lea slicing the bullets that's a good
job because it made no sense when he did
in the first movie so glad they called
it out but if it were another cameo
maybe Professor X but it's like that's
nice one like it's cool yeah and we
already had his super depressing death
are depressing so just let him go to
sleep what about this David Hall or
Legion look at this kid this guy has
severe mental problems but his show
really you can't follow a depressing man
the most recent episode of Legion I'm
not cut up yet oh it's destroying that's
do you wanna watch it ya know it's the
whole cast of gifted and everyone's like
who are these these people it's like
that is okay that show probably it's
gonna get canceled yeah who else could
it possibly be that would get people as
excited as you Jack Captain America I
mean yeah yeah photo that set photo it's
like Avengers four could you pee and it
was like it it looks like an edit from
an old like avenged maybe it's an
Avengers four set photo that somebody
yeah but it also looks like a set photo
from the first Deadpool movie and
they're like edited together it's like
could that be what if it was reversed
yeah they did like a little crossover
between Avengers 4 and Deadpool 2 why it
helps no one out there are both gonna
make all the money right it's not gonna
make us want to see either that I mean
you hope I hope they had time to do some
sort of little like nod to the end of
infinity war like yeah post-credit like
oh well just bro and snap his fingers a
song that would make me really happy I
think you guys know that people have
already seen Deadpool and they've done
like just social tiny little reviews
already and they're saying that the
post-credits scene for Deadpool 2 is
pretty much better the best part of the
movie wait that a knock to the rest of
the movie or people saying that actually
preferred to to the original no yeah we
are seeing it on Monday though so we'll
report back soon for and we'll have like
of course you know reviews of the
post-credits scene and a review of the
movie and full breakdown and all that
good stuff that we do for every movie
well yeah I did we've done a couple
trailer breakdowns for this movie and I
didn't Colossus show up at some point
maybe in one of the trailers where looks
like Colossus and there was there's
there's definitely Colossus but there
was a tease that it looked like
juggernaut was in it so that was pretty
like well yeah I tried not to tell you
what it looks like when they're in that
big convoy there's like a thermal scan
of someone in the back of the truck and
it's like this enormous person and then
Colossus is connecting punching this
round dome was like a real honest-to-god
Colossus three that's read yeah blaring
yeah lines are all mixed up so yeah it'd
be nice to see Colossus in his human
form you know I think in the first step
will he'd spent the whole time and we
did three movies of him act for kinda
because he was in like a little bit in
the first one more in the second movie
in the third and he popped up in Days of
Future past as the yeah school got
infiltrated yeah well let us know what
he you what K mail you would like to see
in Deadpool too if you've already seen
it Channing Tatum's gambit I mean that
would be the next like the goofy one
that they could kind of make fun of and
now that the merger looks like it's kind
of happening I don't think origins they
were yeah yeah maybe nice you know
there's this whole scene in the movie
that we've seen thrown Australis where
there's like a casting line up and
that's where like Peter shows up and
Domino so they could just have like so
many really good you could make deep
cuts like David Haller from Legion or
Channing Tatum is gambit and they're
beep or hanging herself too much just
miss them however you want be like no
you you're not relatable enough her what
if it's Duke do you guys don't know dupe
is this weird green slime or looking
dude who was a mutant but he doesn't
speak English he just speaks his own
little like street slang
do yeah it's like you can't read that's
not my yeah yeah let us know what cameo
you would like to see and yeah if you
have seen the movie don't spoil in the
comments please I know a lot of you like
living countries that awesome you get
like advanced access to movies but here
in America for most of us the release
date is going to be like Thursday /
Friday this our favorite tweets are when
you guys are like man enough spoiler but
why would Spiderman die at the end if
you had to guess good reasons like you
what are you doing yeah I always get
like paragraph long dm's it's like don't
read this in case you haven't seen the
movie yet but immediately spoiler we're
gonna try it like I had for infinity
where how to put like filtered were
muted words on my Twitter just like
block out anything and thank God I did
cuz a moment the moment I took off the
filter I right after I saw the movie
just like barrage of of tweets asking
about spin' xand it's like thank God I
saw the earliest possible screening that
I could because if I had seen it like a
little bit later man come on guys
but anyway yeah let us know in the
comments below what you're saying
demanding everyone silence didn't work
from the filmmakers Russo brothers like
deleted all their social media accounts
like for bread before infinity war came
out and was just like hey we're not
gonna show you anything until like the
movies gone
the only tweet that they've tweeted
since then is a the Infinity Gauntlet
given the middle finger to well let's
move on to this week's trivia question
keeping things in the realm of Deadpool
it sounds like yeah yeah yeah and our
question is in the first a Deadpool
movie whose memoir are weighed in
Vanessa reading for the lint holiday
during that calendar girl sex montage
lady alright we have all of our
questions here in the box
as always we will reveal the answer to
the trivia question at the end of the
episode and the closest answer as
decided by our judges will do our
sign-off goodbyes meanwhile the loser
will have to cleverly riff on our in
other news headlines and it'll be super
fun
quick update with some big news from
this week guys we all want to we won't
cover all the big news stories that you
need to know about Rick and Morty
announced that it will get 70 more
episodes Adult Swim greenlit them that's
guys it's like seven more seasons if you
do ten episodes the season now there's
no word on when season four will
premiere but now they have like you know
money and the contract to work on it but
this contract will bring the total
number of Rick and Morty episodes to 100
that's crazy
I never thought it's like it's unheard
of to get an episode order that high and
one go well I just remember the other
day it was like although a bit nervous
because I didn't know the future of the
show boom basically what is that like
more than double we're gonna more than
double what you've already done right
that's insane if somebody really liked
about animation actually because like
with Voltron on Netflix or whatever they
I guess because of animation production
they order like the batch like I mean
it's not just one season and we'll see
it's like know you're gonna be on four
yeah so it's it makes you feel it makes
you feel more comfortable that the show
has the time to go where they're going
nothing this is the most serial I show
on TV I mean yeah it has a correct
creator do you kind of hear 70 episodes
in your life oh boy hopefully they take
their time with it and don't rush it you
know I would say I love season 3 a ton
it did lose some of the a bit of the
spark that season 1 & 2 had that might
just be because like the fan attention
started to explode in season 3 and then
he had a like weird hype for things that
weren't necessarily in the spirit of
Rick and Morty and it started to lose
some of the innocence that the first two
seasons had for me personally I just
finally hear them marching on me right
now
I like the Szechuan mcdonalds debacle
were the kids and the adults mainly
we're freaking out at McDonald's
employees yeah proud of you guys I can't
wait to see what conversation we're
having it during season 10
long beards and yeah okay everyone
Avengers infinity war left us with some
big questions about the future of the
MCU and yeah spoiler warning how will
Marvel resolve half of the universe
getting snapped out of existence when we
come back for Avengers 4 well Gwyneth
Paltrow who of course plays Pepper Potts
teased a possible twist for the next
movie in an interview this week and yeah
one final warning if you don't want to
know anything about the upcoming film
but this is this is out there this is
out there
okay Paltrow was asked about peppers
relationship with Tony Stark throughout
the films and she said quote she
obviously starts as this as his dutiful
assistant and then the relationship
evolves and now this decade later
they're married and they have a child
the relationship has evolved in all the
ways that great romances evolve what
Marvel Studios this is what happens when
you shoot two movies at the same time
your actors get confused I start
divulging details about the wrong movie
they forget where it is so yes we're
looking at now it's out there let's talk
about it by a decade later Paltrow seems
to be hinting at a time jump with the
next Avengers movie taking place long
after that Oh snaps half of everyone
away and a life just has moved on they
have a kid now that's insane also be
referring to at the beginning of the
movie their hat they're getting ready to
get married and they're having the
conversation about having kids the
Morgan conversation yeah she could be
referring to that a decade later seems
specific to me and if it's true it
complicates the idea of simply resetting
or reversing thanasis move like any
attempt to undo the snap might undo the
new lives that Tony and the others have
built in the aftermath of this event and
it presents a huge narrative stakes for
all the characters like even if they're
presented with the way to bring down
Thanos and fix everything they might not
even want to embark on that mission at
all because maybe they're kind of but it
makes it interest it makes an
interesting choice right like do I give
up this life that I've kind of moved on
with do I have to go back what do you
guys find most interesting about I've
interest for opening with the time job
that way it was I read this earlier I
thought that she was just referred
referencing the first Iron Man movie to
now I thought that it was meant that it
had been
yeah because also for you like think
about a 10 year time jump that's how
long it took Captain Marvel ditched
every other major event of course it
took her 10 years just to get your goods
she had either other obligations or she
just didn't want to come yeah if it does
mean 10 years I don't do that don't be
don't be so mean also you guys it took
you guys 10 years to figure out what to
do next some sense fish I also feel like
if you do the time jump yeah
you're not time jumping to like hey
everybody's happy it's like Mad Max
after half the population yeah it was a
way I don't think there's like hey we're
all living normal lives but now what
it's like no there's not I don't think
there's a recovery period after it could
be like post-apocalyptic at that point
and they just have a kid because they
have something like they'd like to do
that I think kind of like gained
popularity specifically with x-men in
Age of Apocalypse and stuff like that
but they've sensed on with the Avengers
and stuff like that if somebody from an
apocalyptic future comes in so like Dan
of snaps oh no gravy er Tony fireflies
in future like guys it's so much worse
than you know like we got I mean I
married have a kid with it is feeling
more and more x-men to me and I feel
like this is when you induce time-travel
to as a solution you do your removal
stakes it's like well what was the point
of all of that and I as much as I love
x-men like they're all over the place we
thought they've been doing the fact that
they've got two different actors playing
the same character in different what
decades basically I don't know I want it
simplified I think that this is just
going to out Road trying to be relevant
trying to decode I mean trying to parse
out exactly what she says you're right
she could be referring to the decades
since the first Iron Man 2 now I just
think in context of talking about having
a new kid that's that's different like
she's not revealed to be pregnant in the
movie they're just talking about the
hypothetical of having conceived it so
she doesn't want to and man's famous
power is dream future yes famous
yeah it's it's it's very interesting and
I that's why I hope like we talked about
in past episodes the options with how
you would fix tannaz his decision right
time travels one option as I talked
about the idea of like jumping into a
different reality Rick and Morty style
that's why I would hope that if they do
go this way maybe not time travel but
jumping into another reality or some
other kind of dimension or realm
something that we haven't seen over and
over again movies someone actually
watches new rocks let me see if I can
get the name correct they they sent me
this theory and at first I was like a
lot of people sent theories and like you
know it's like it's kind of hard to like
like figure I'm all out but this one was
really sad it was from Rachel Evans
there we go she mentioned that what if
the idea that when dr. strange says this
is the only way that it doesn't mean
that dr. strange loses and he disappears
it's that everyone who's done we're
seeing we're not seeing people who are
being erased
everyone who remains is kind of like in
a limbo state and everyone who races
know the person who lived and every
weirdest thing the point of view of
people who were actually already done
that's a super fascinating I was like
yeah it's already week so what's the
port of the next movie it's almost kind
of like this is actually hell you know
like we didn't make it we're the ghosts
yeah that would be super exciting to see
yeah well let us know what you make of
this is it just like Gwyneth Paltrow
miss speaking do you think this could
actually happen if so how do you think
would be the best way to handle this so
it doesn't follow down the steps of
people who have maybe use time travel to
indulgently to fix things which I don't
think we want to see but alright another
quick update from the news this week
solo a Star Wars story is surprising
everyone with its advance ticket sales
far higher than anticipated besting
black panther sales and coming second
only to Avengers infinity where we're
talking about advance sales yeah last
week we chat about how enthusiasm
appears to be lower for Han Solo in the
Star Wars brand but according to these
numbers we may have been a bit off just
kind of editorializing a bit here I'm
curious to dig into the data science of
this like I wonder if movies like well
Force awakens but then also like black
panther and infinity war caused movie
theaters to open up advance ticket sales
more
expand it so that it allowed yeah I
don't know how advance ticket sales work
like maybe AMC in in Regal in our
theaters around the country like oh
we'll just offer more and more advance
ticket sales because Black Panther
proved that this is a thing that people
will invest and then it doesn't like are
really actually excited for solo and I'm
like putting my own spin and biasing the
news I don't know I don't know I but
yeah I think this is it's all money it's
all like people are gonna go watch all
these movies anyway in Disney's probably
like let's just like pressure these
things like it's gonna do well trust us
offer more advance ticket sales and then
people will pay for it and they have
they they definitely proved me wrong
last week what do you think the response
is gonna be for solo because I feel like
this one has a weird baggage because
it's it's a it's associated with one of
the most iconic characters in the series
but played by a different actor and
there's tell you in the directness which
what I mean but you know you feel but
I'm how do you think general audiences
are gonna respond I will I sorry hi I
went to the premiere last night he's
cool it was so cool and it was very
interesting to chat with a bunch of
people diehard fans and people that have
never seen Star Wars before or never
really indulged in Star Wars before and
the people that are hardcore fans were a
little bit not shell-shocked but they
needed a lot more time to process it and
they were just like you know I've got
cousins whereas the people that knew
nothing going in had the best time so I
think it's my understanding is that
Disney isn't about pandering and making
sure that the die-hard fans who were
already invested in Star Wars stay
mm-hmm they're actually more concerned
about bringing in a whole new audience
yeah it makes sense it's hard to please
both of those also yeah like other
people that don't know the first came
out in seventies I remember when force
awakens came out and China was like yeah
we don't know who these characters yeah
and there's a second biggest audience in
the world so it's like yeah we're gonna
make movies for them
and I did identically it just did shot
right out of my brain there's my
nephew's I have seen like the force
awakens in the last Jedi and I think
they saw Phantom Menace and some of the
other prequels but knew those far more
than the original trilogy yeah I think
there is the hardcore nerds for Star
Wars got all their favorite stuff in the
prequels with the trade agreements in
that diner that they had got everything
you want here it's our turn yeah well I
yeah I I expect the movie to be pleasing
like I think we'll have a good time with
it and it like it's Ron Howard and it's
Disney there's so much like quality
control over these things I don't think
we'll walk out be like what the hell was
that but who knows I with so much
excitement for it I maybe I should just
like get off my high horse and just
enjoy I'm gonna go in and try and treat
it as if it's a standalone space heist
movie yeah without any pre expectations
of what should fit within this world or
whatever and I think I'm gonna be way
more on board with that mindset yeah I
get a very speed racer vibe with Emile
Hirsch I actually really like to be very
certain look at which house key Speed
Racer I think there was a lot of fun I
didn't like a flashing lot I really okay
with Avengers infinity war behind us
everyone's focus now shifted the future
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
Marvel head Kevin Feige has been
particularly quiet about what movies
will be in phase four perhaps to avoid
any hints about who will survive the
next Avengers movie but one fan posts it
on reddit a dream version of the
upcoming MCU line up with some
interesting title options there's
Avengers infinity crusade Spider Man
learning curve Doctor Strange nightmare
Thor god of thunder now these again man
in the wasp a little bit want them to be
a bit limited now again this is not real
this is fan made and it's compatible
with fan suggested titles that have been
popping up on different social media for
all these movies now hopefully Black
Panthers sequel will be better than a
Black Panther returns and Captain Marvel
if she gets a sequel have a better title
than Captain Marvel 2 is great but now
perhaps moving fast fans are speculating
that infinity crusade could be the next
title because in the it's a title the
Marvel comic storyline that comes after
the Infinity Gauntlet and the affinity
war and it follows Adam warlock as he
tries to like use the gauntlet wisely I
would say might been in the actual
events of infinity crusade wouldn't
maybe not make the best Avengers for a
movie but and in my opinion the word
crusade does evoke a classic knights of
the round table kind of adventure that
could be kind of fun to see that it what
title would you guys like to see for the
next Avengers movie and maybe some of
these others that are I think infinity
crusade is a fun title but I don't know
why they would have kept it such a
secret then cuz they've really made we
are weirdly big deal about keeping the
title and raps they've said it's a
spoiler basically expand should be
scared yeah so so I was thinking like
cuz I was actually thinking if you're
gonna go with a comic series even though
this one doesn't roll off the tongue
like infinity Greece say does the famous
imperative before yeah because it's that
was a big cosmic crossover and and I
think famous is probably I mean maybe
big play a big part in this one and I
honestly wouldn't be surprised if they
continue taking cribbing from Infinity
Gauntlet that story if the Avengers have
to team up with Thanos which I think
would provide a lot of like a lot of
character tension because obviously they
have all the reasons in the world he
heard of yeah he just a few just a
couple so of people it that's the only
one I can think of that you'd why would
matter to keep it a secret on any level
yeah or maybe like infinity sacrifice or
something like that or something
implying the death suggested because the
scrolls and Captain Marvel Secret
Invasion but it's like there's no
possible way they've got too many other
things to wrap up from infinity war to
like dive into a whole mother crossover
event yeah you know agreed I'm just
looking at the themes of Hollywood at
the moment and it needs to have rise
shadow also think about this because
they said it's supposed to hurt so it
could be like Avengers Robert Downey jr.
is not coming back anymore you can't
stop
spider-man still just remember your
favorite character is real death I also
think it's just a middle finger
spider-man graduation yeah because it's
supposed to take place during his senior
year yeah they're going with a school I
think that would be going for the third
one yeah no more I don't know what no
more means but a learning curve I think
would be a really cool title for a
second one related supposed to take
place during his senior year right cuz
now we've jumped ahead to the timeline
super confused right and the character
is currently a my age that's a good
question I was seeing an article was
talking about how do you after that
movie comes out like two months after
the next Avengers how do you advertise
for considering it would be a spoiler
for the and then and I think answer is
you go for it you spoil it or like the
movie that you promote maybe doesn't
have Peter Parker in it like I don't
know it's weird to have a spider movie
without spider-man in it but that
actually is a really good he's been
brought up like Donald Glover played his
uncle the reason why ultimate spider-man
shows up is because Peter dies and
that's been so Myles takes up the mantle
yeah Peter's gone waitin on my house
movie so that would be so that would be
confusing
yeah I wonder percent Peter parks are
going to be back and I would it would
shock me if they don't just straight
like once they see pretty shocking yeah
mile-high club
lucky it's happening in this movie I
like the god of thunder title for
another thorn I would love to see a
fourth or maybe especially after
Ragnarok I
mahalo might be a better name than god
of thunder Mahalo
you know using another kind of like Odin
as Guardi and well that means the
Valkyries will be there as well or just
Valkyrie which that's got to happen
right the all-female team up thing
that's got to be in the world just a
second panelist because I rewatched it
for a third time this week and it was
like cool and it ends really fast and I
was like oh yeah it would be cool yeah
hey we got to make a room for tracks to
try and convince everybody's invisible
right you're Captain American I have
three extra lines we got to make room
for a dress to make everybody think he's
invisible worth it
what title though he pitches your titles
for what we would love to see in these
other ones like let's I mean you know
Kevin Feige is reading all of these
threads he needs ideas how he comes up
with it let's help them do they have not
produced anything that they promised and
they're like don't worry come on guys I
guess this is open for everyone I
thought I just started to like Whittle
it down to like what fans want
spider-man the black costume oh great
thanks guys but yeah we want to hear
from you but now it's time for us to
move on to our new rock stars news
lightning right now man every time
that's a that's a hard one to pull out
hey you guys tweeted us these questions
I'm gonna fire them on my co-host they
gotta answer them as quickly and without
hesitation as possible are we ready
everyone
okay mod at cure X sire Sirius wants to
know how Ironman handle a lack of toilet
paper while while alone on that planet
he's AI will supply she's gonna fly them
off like yes opening minutes of Avengers
for Iron Man's like I'm gonna ya nebula
does it go anywhere with a roll of
shortening this isn't her handle but
India Brazil wants to know what would a
90s era grunge band with nebula mantis
Valkyrie Groot and Gomorrha and it'd be
called wants to know what your 90s era
grunge band name will be for people in
that bed I take the first letter of all
their name okay from an era when I was
feeling reach into your soul and Paletta
name the Jessica Jones's tramble or
tramble yeah all right DJ Stephanie
Kelly wants to know do you think Hulk
not coming out to help in the fight as a
product of performance anxiety due to
planet earth hating Hulk or a bigger
problem that they will explore I think
it'd be really interesting I was on a
friend show a friend of mine named star
she brought up that maybe Hulk was
because as far as Hulk knows Thor's dead
so maybe he was it was something like
that and I actually think that's really
interesting as opposed to what I think
it actually is I think it's he got his
butt handed to him and I guess Hulk is a
wuss now and can't take it he doesn't
like losing yeah it's a very different
character than he was even in the first
Avengers yeah and they've kind of made
him I I don't know I I think I think
it's we're the Roosters actually talked
about this a little bit he is also kind
of tired of saving Banner which I also
think is actually more interesting than
just
I got hurt yeah so I hope they emphasize
that more in four because hope is one of
my favorite characters for me I've
always been a robot just been good at
fooling them honest candor Ella what
would be your own creative way to defeat
Thanos you may use any avenger that you
would like to oh I don't need any
Avengers cuz I'm gonna get them with
riddles
mmm wet walks on four legs and then two
legs in three legs oh you know
that'sthat's human being damn soul stone
gives you a lot of knowledge well I'm
gonna find a riddle that he won't know
perhaps something from the DC universe
something one of Riddler's riddles
because I can do that and he can't
I got him guys I got the guy have
everyone be my friends forever
and no one can ever leave
this one made out of cloth like in the
cop in the cop yeah the comics the the
makeup of the Goblin the comics is a
little confusing like as a infinity
glove yeah it's more like a glove and
you know what the stones are all
different color you can tell him a
riddle and he's like he's just so tired
of talking to me and that's really what
the trick was hey guys thanks for asking
this oh I'm gonna wear this for the rest
cuz it looks like I'm mad alright
everyone thanks for joining us those
questions coming up next we're gonna
take a look at what we got in the
pipeline for videos coming out on this
channel in the next week next week is
Deadpool week so we're gonna have a
Deadpool review that'll be this New York
sirs news next week
we're also gonna look at the Deadpool
post-credit scene and what happens in
that you know and this is a video that
you might see we saw James Gunn tweet
this week that there are in there are
Easter eggs in both the guardians of the
galaxy movies that people have not found
yet so we're gonna look into that and
see if we can find exactly what this
missing Easter Egg is we've reviewed the
movies a couple times it's it's stuff
group has said that he decided in his
mind like saying I have a bad feeling
about this they just like retro actively
decided that's where the quote was we'll
find out what it is okay
now comes the time for a 15-second shout
outs where each of us has 15 seconds to
shout out or plug or or tramble about
anything alright earlier but I want to
do a shout out for because the episode
was wonderful this week Legion there's 5
episodes of season 2 but only 8 maybe 10
in season 1 and you watch season 1 on
Hulu and if get the FX app you can watch
season 2 yeah check it out
amazing for my shout out I'm going to
many of you saw it and already tweets
about it Donald Glover Childish
Gambino's this is America music video oh
man oh man this is so great and yeah I
wish we had time to like do a breakdown
on this we don't normally do breakdown
of like hip hop music videos it's just
not really what we do although this is
so dense and so amazing so full of
meaning I wish I could there are other
plenty of other sources like I think
Washington Post and
other people kind of broke down the
imagery of it but man it's a really
great like history lesson and stuff that
you really do need to know about there's
a whole other story happening in the
background of that music video that yeah
we should all learn more about for sure
sweet my 15-second shadow I don't know
why Sam didn't mention it only stupid
answers had their hundredth episode show
yeah not long ago and it was amazing and
SModcast got a little bit in there but
DJ and sounded an amazing job and i
think you're going to release it as a
podcast and there'll be like a video
version of it too you can watch like the
whole thing and there's gonna be a fun
adventure style vlog that you guys will
find links to on our social medias
alright so that was on behalf of you
real quickly here's my pun do a [ __ ]
Jurassic Park meet Star Wars so tractor
that's good that's a good bit guys
that's good if you guys go to chaos
theory comic dot-com you can find my
comic book it's volume 2 of my series
chaos theory kind of zombies vs
dinosaurs so if you like the movies we
talked about here I found my pitch I was
trying like if you thought of infinity
Wars the greatest crossover ever does it
have zombies or dinosaurs no this does
so you might want to check that out it's
every crazy thing I ever wanted to put
in a comic and it's a hunt it's 5 issues
100 pages if you contribute $25 or more
which is a physical tear it's where you
get a package and you're coming from new
rock stars you can go to the comments
section on the Kickstarter page and you
can say hey I'm from any rock stars and
I will throw into your package a
postcard map of the United States there
it is boom has been in this universe and
it's gone through some stuff right so
there's a ton of ears prints there's all
the stuff I know I'm over my 15 seconds
you can also original cover art like
wait wait he's got a glare but say you
can get original cover by our amazing
cover artist Tom Neeley and prints from
other amazing artists and a bunch of
cool stuff and I really want to make
this comic happen so please go check it
out and contribute if you can we're all
trying to do cool yeah guys get on that
okay finally let's return to our trivia
question that we asked I'm gonna move it
here here just to remind everyone I'm
sorry Sam magic yeah you have the power
of the Universe now okay so our trivia
question to remind us what it is in the
first Deadpool movie whose memoir are
await in Vanessa reading for the lint
holiday during the calendar girl sex
montage let's go down the line and see
what we said sorry mom mom said I've
never left a blank answer on a car
before and I don't intend to start today
so I'll say share okay Barack Obama is
DJ o of Hope or I don't know what is
it's called yeah that sounds like a good
one
and then a blank of a Geisha oh so
Memoirs of a Geisha oh that's good
that's a good answer did you just
realize what it was yeah Eric wrote Gwen
Stefani
it's a hollaback girl callback maybe no
no that's right no it's not right the
answer is Mario Lopez Mario Lopez's
Mario Lopez wasn't there that bit with
him on Access Hollywood not Access
Hollywood it was whatever the show
that's extra where he like tackled him
to announce that the movie would be
r-rated yeah and so I think maybe they
well that's a cut we were all wrong all
of us were wrong but who was the
wrongest judges Sam wasn't even a person
listen it was a real novel it was Saved
by the Bell of memoir wrote a memoir
about us Saved by the Bell years it's so
much more than a pig all right and who
was our winner Maud is our winner okay
great
sure pop culture I get it yeah okay so
say a mod we'll get to our goodbyes Sam
we'll do our in other news headlines
I'll set up the headlines Sam we'll have
to quickly riff on it in some hilarious
way and I'm sure we'll all love it okay
everyone ready to go yes
in other news Robert Downey jr. original
Iron Man suit was stolen from a Los
Angeles prop warehouse he stole our
hearts great okay next up Universal
Studios Hollywood which is literally
right across the street from us right
now
announced that the Jurassic Park river
ride will close down to be replaced by a
Jurassic world ride okay yeah because
that was a really dumb move
hey we'll throw the funniest okay so
closing down that fossil you know what
other fossil you know what actually a
pretty solid like if you if you had more
commitment to that it's really all right
next up Harley Quinn's upcoming spin-off
movie has been described by insiders as
an r-rated girl gang film is going to
the well it yeah I hope it's like Romeo
Michele's high school reunion
no there's what you think of when you
think of r-rated girl game I thought of
the Avengers actors got matching tattoos
of a symbol that fans have tried to
decode for clues for the next movie
what's the symbol thank you it will put
in a give Eric just a week it he's got
you covered
we've analyzed cakes yeah some more yeah
though there's one more here we go my
shirt and then finally the Russo
brothers said that Scarlet Witch lost
her Russian accent over time because her
character is on the run and she's trying
to blend in well hey if she couldn't
blend in with that Russian accent might
as well try blending in and the band
you're Luke Scott I had it there in the
beginning let's go to Scotland I try to
say a rug hurts Scott
huh sounds like a great Scot this is
great turn up the heater when this
starts right every song is what when it
starts man I'd make people forget I'm a
I'd make it so that he said I never get
I never have to do this again on the run
and I haven't lost my accent yeah it's
just like it wasn't and BlackWidow makes
sense because it's been our whole career
maybe she could have improved her accent
back with us to spy female leads with
red hair that are both supposed to be
Russian or Eastern European I'm starting
to look lose it take away goodbye
congratulations
that was just life-giving thank you Sam
if you do want more of Sam bashes what
do you call that
like just stamp it sustenance us today
Sam Basha so you can get that good that
goodness that gold Erik Voss a TA Voss
what do you mean tweeting about lately
cool story bro coach I've also got DJ
Wooldridge at DJ talks trash which is an
indicator of what you'll get and he
likes to preface and warn so that no
one's like wait a second he's like
talking trash full transparency
my name's more Garrett aka winner and
the fact that I won with you share like
damn yeah yeah if you could turn back
time how would you say I would save spot
learn yeah that's good that's all
comment down low and tweet I'm sorry I
won I'm just gonna go for it yeah he
rock stars you can lack this video
if you feel like a winner share it
around if you've got friends that also
want in geek out and subscribe to do
rock stars because I've got over a
million and that's [ __ ]
good thanks guys be back next week
thanks for having me